STEVE: IN THAT THEIR DIFFERENT
WAYS, TWO OF THIS WEEK'S BIGGEST
NEWS STORIES SHINES A SPOTLIGHT
ON HOW THE SWAMP WORKS.
THE IRAN NUCLEAR DEAL AND
MICHAEL COHEN'S DEAL.
WE GET TO THE BOTTOM OF IT ALL
IN TONIGHT'S SWAMP WATCH.
♪♪
BRITAIN, FRANCE AND GERMANY
LOBBIED FURIOUSLY TOE TRY TO
STOP TRUMP FROM DITCHING THE
IRAN NUCLEAR DEAL AND NOW
THEY'RE TRYING TO KEEP IT ALIVE.
THEY DRESS IT UP AS HIGH
PRINCIPLE BUT FOR THEM IT'S
ABOUT MORE MONEY FOR THEIR BIG
BUSINESS CRONIES.
THE SWAMP IS GLOBAL.
BRITAIN HAS PUSHED THEIR TELEKOM
COMPANY TRYING TO MODERNIZE THE
NETWORK.
AND IN 2017 BRITISH OFFICIALS OF
AND IN 2017 BRITISH OFFICIALS OC
AND IN 2017 BRITISH OFFICIALS OA
AND IN 2017 BRITISH OFFICIALS OS
AGREED TO $715 MILLION DEAL.
GERMANY IS EVEN MORE SWAMPY,
AFTER SANCTIONS WERE LIFTED, CAR
MAKER VOLKSWAGEN REACHED AN
AGREEMENT TO SELL TWO OF THEIR
MODELS THERE AND THE GERMAN
MANUFACTURING GIANT SEEMEN
SIGNED DEALS.
BUT HERE'S THE SWAMPIEST GERMAN
AND THIS IS TRULY SHOCKING.
ONE OF THE BIGGEST IMPACTS IS
WOULD BE ON ENERGY.
IN RUSSIA, THEY BOTH HAVE
EXPWRESES IN IRAN.
GUESS WHO IS HEAD OF THE
EXECUTIVE BOARD AND CHAIMPLE OF
THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS AT IN
ORDERSTREAM.
GAR HART SCHRODER, THE FORMER
GERMAN LEADER IS ON THE BOARD OF
RUSSIA'S BIGGEST ENERGY
COMPANIES.
SINCE RUSSIA HAS NO ECONOMY
APART FROM ENERGY, THAT'S
BASICALLY LIKE BEING ON THE
BOARD OF RUSSIA.
AND THE ELITES ACCUSE DONALD
TRUMP OF COLLUSION.
PERHAPS THE COUNTRY DEEPEST IN
THE IRAN SWAMP IS FRANCE.
AIRBUS SIGNED A DEAL WITH IRAN
AIR TO SELL 100 PLANES AROUND
$19 BILLION.
ANOTHER FRENCH CRAFT MAKER STUCK
A $216 MILLION BILL.
FRENCH OIL GIANT SIGNED A
20-YEAR CONTRACT WITH IRAN AND
CHINESE OIL COMPANY TO DEVELOP
AN IRANIAN GAS FIELD AND A
FRENCH CAR MAKER GOT A DEAL TO
OPEN AN IRANIAN PLANT.
IT TURNS OUT THAT ONE-FIFTH OF
THE ENTIRE GLOBAL MARKET IS IN
IRAN.
AND YOU'LL BE INTERESTED TO
DISCOVER THAT THE ROTHSCHILD
BANKER IS NONE OWE
BANKER IS NONE OTHER THARN THAN
EMANUEL MACRON.
WE TAKE THEM FOR SERIOUSLY WHEN
THEY COME AFTER DONALD TRUMP FOR
PULLING OUT OF THE NUCLEAR DEAL
IF THEY WEREN'T UP TO THEIR
NECKS WITH OTHER DEALS WITH
IRAN.
THE OTHER STORY IN THE SPOTLIGHT
IS DONALD TRUMP'S FORMER FIXER,
MICHAEL COHEN.
THE DRUG GIANT CONFIRMED THAT IT
PAID COHEN $1.2 MILLION FOR A
CONSULTING CONTRACT.
HE REACHED OUT IN EARLY 2017
PROMISING ACCESS TO THE
PRESIDENT AND MANY MOST
INFLUENTIAL OFFICIALS IN THE NEW
ADMINISTRATION.
NOVARTIS JUMPED AT THE
INFORMATION.
IT'S THE KIND OF CORRUPTION THAT
THE PHARMACEUTICAL COMPANIES
JUMP AT ALL OF THE TIME.
THEY SPENT OVER $8 MILLION
LOBBYING THE U.S. GOVERNMENT
JUST LAST YEAR, SPENT OVER
45 MILLION LOBBYING SINCE 2012.
AND THREE-QUARTERS OF THE
LOBBYISTS THAT NOVARTIS HIRED IN
2017 HAVE PREVIOUSLY HELD
GOVERNMENT JOBS, INCLUDING BOB
DOLE AND FORMER HOUSE WAYS AND
MEANS COMMITTEE MEMBER, JIM MA
CAREERRY.
NOVARTIS HAS DONATED $168,000 TO
POLITICAL CANDIDATES JUST IN THE
2018 ELECTION CYCLE.
AND REMEMBER BECAUSE MICHAEL
COHEN WASN'T TECHNICALLY HIRED
AS A LOBBYIST BUT CONSULTANT,
NOVARTIS DIDN'T HAVE TO
DISCLOSES THEIR CONTRACT.
WELL
THLL
THEL
THE OTHER DRUG COMPANIES THAT
BUY THE OUTCOMES THAT THEY WANT
FROM YOUR GOVERNMENT.
NOVARTIS WASN'T ALONE.
MICHAEL COHEN APPROACHED AT&T
WITH THE PAY TO PLAY TEACH AND
THEY GAVE HIM A
600 MILLION-DOLLAR FOR AN INSIDE
TRACK TO HELP WITH THEIR BID TO
BUY TIME WARNER.
AT&T'S CEO RANDALL STEPHENS
TRIED TO BLAME IT ALL ON BOB
QUINN, WHO WAS THROWN UNDER THE
BUS, FORCED TO RETIRE.
STEPHENSON SAID THAT HIRING
MICHAEL COHEN WAS A BIG MISTAKE.
YEAH, RIGHT.
THE ONLY MISTAKE WAS GETTING
CAUGHT.
AT&T SPENDS MORE THAN
$60 MILLION ON FAD RALE LOBBYING
EACH OF THE LAST 20 YEARS.
AND 86 OF THEIR 114 LOBBYISTS
HAVE PREVIOUSLY HELD GOVERNMENT
JOBS.
IN THE TWEEP ELECTION, AT&T GAVE
$4.7 MILLION TO HUNDREDS OF
CANDIDATES IN GROUPS IN BOTH
PARTIES, DONATING $1.5 MILLION
FOR THE DEMOCRATIC CONVENTION
AND $4.2 MILLION ON THE
REPUBLICAN CONVENTION.
ON TOP OF THAT AT&T RANDALL
STEPHENSON PERSONALLY GIVES
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS TO D.C.
POLITICIANS, 1,000 TO PAUL RYAN,
2700 TO JOHN McCAIN, 10,000 TO
THE NATIONAL REPUBLICAN SENATE
TOIRL COMMITTEE.
NOT TO MENTION THE THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS HE'S DONATED TO HIS OWN
COMPANY'S POLITICAL ACTION
COMMITTEE.
THIS IS THE KIND OF CORRUPTION
THAT DONALD TRUMP WAS ELECTED TO
STOP.
AND LET'S BE FAIR.
HE'S DELIVERED SOME OF HIS DRAIN
THE SWAMP PLEDGES, LIKE CRACKING
DOWN ON THE RESOLVING DOOR
BETWEEN GOVERNMENT AND LOBBYING.
AND MICHAEL COHEN'S PEDDLING
DIDN'T WORK.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION TOOK
AT&T TO COURT TO BLOCK THE
MERGER.
BUT THE SIGHT OF A TRUMP INSIDER
RUNNING AROUND TRYING TO HELP
BIG CORPORATIONS IS AN INSULT TO
EVERY TRUMP VOTER.
JUST TODAY "THE WALL STREET
JOURNAL" IS REPORTING THAT
MICHAEL COHEN PUSHED HIS SWAMPY
SERVICE TO FORD AS WELL.
DONALD TRUMP WAS ELECTED TO BE
THE VOICE FOR THE VOICELESS, TO
HELP THE FORGOTTEN MEN AND WOMEN
OF AMERICA, NOT TO HELP BIG
BUSINESS GET ITS WAY IN
WASHINGTON.
WHAT PART OF DRAIN THE SWAMP DID
MICHAEL COHEN NOT UNDERSTAND.
POINTING THIS OUT IS NOT BEING
DISLOYAL TO THE PRESIDENT.
IT'S MICHAEL COHEN WHO HAS LET
THE PRESIDENT DOWN BY 'EM
EMBARRASSING HIM AND UNDERMINING
ONE OF HIS MOST IMPORTANT
PROMISE TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
MICHAEL COHEN SHOULD APOLOGIZE,